baby jonas
is here i feel like a new woman sophie
turner and husband joe jonas have
welcomed their first child
and now there are just as many junior
jonases as there are jonas brothers
[Music]
joe and sophie are already loving aunt
and uncle to kevin's two daughters
news first broke of turner's pregnancy
in february
though she didn't confirm it at the time
or maybe
she did suddenly sophie's baby bump was
soon on full display on
outings with her hubby during turner's
pregnancy a source told e.t
joe and sophie are excited to be new
parents and have been enjoying the
process of getting ready for their baby
the whole jonas family is looking
forward to showering the new addition
with love
the power couple started dating in 2016
after jonah slid into the game of
thrones stars dms
on instagram
[Music]
in may 2019 the two married during a
surprise ceremony in las vegas
following the billboard music awards
which was live streamed
by diplo for a while there it was a
little bit of bad blood but
[Laughter]
we got over pretty quick and uh he ended
up djing
our wedding so he made up for it oh that
makes it
a free superstar dj you know
two months after their vegas wedding the
lovebirds tied the knot again
during a formal ceremony in france the
impact of falling in love has made me
want to be a better man
a better person shortly before their
nuptials
e.t caught up with turner at the game of
thrones premiere where she gushed
over her man it means so much to have
him here it's just like the best support
the best person to calm me down and keep
me calm and
if i end up crying i have a shoulder to
cry on
so it's good i'm so happy that he's here
[Music]